in key central train station and about
to go to hockey and hot heat I've done
about five minutes of research on this
place so I have absolutely no idea what
I'm getting into
[Music]
how to keep Ukraine way out in the far
east of the country 30 kilometers from
the Russian border first impressions it
was it was dark but I could see a lot of
street life like a lot of people on the
street a lot of young people
[Music]
day one these buildings here this
architecture it does it for me this
constructivism such creative lines such
beautiful proportions they have a
building here I think it's the Opera
Opera House like a small planet landed
on earth it's just this massive hunk of
weight it's so ugly it's a little bit
beautiful there's all these kids outside
of it
skateboarding people hanging out there's
foul
[Music]
sashka is crushing it on the skateboard
here
nice to meet all of you this is what I
so much love about Ukraine is that it's
properly mixed up so you have that like
Soviet relic behind me and then yes
[Music]
and then these side streets treeline
strat side streets some quiet some with
little gardens like apartments Garden
Street
[Music]
okay first impression of this square was
okay here's a big cobblestone parking
lot but then it opens up into this stuff
this is super impressive this
architecture and then you get into it
and it's like design and style is in the
DNA of this place because you go into
that metro and it's the most beautiful
metro I've seen like no joke the most
most outrageous metro stops there was
one that just looked like a crazy
science experiment
[Music]
a lot of eclectic businesses here like
coffee shops restaurants world class you
won't you won't get these in a lot of
American cities like it's just not even
that progressive in many USA even in a
lot of Europe and then you find yourself
you know near the front lines of a war a
country that's gone through a lot of
turbulence a lot right but there's this
creative energy like there's this
amazing creative energy coming out of
that and so it's designing building and
operating all these cool businesses here
very good yes and then there's build
this new part and it's beautiful it's
like done well and then you come out of
that and there's a massive old Soviet
mural and then there's one of the most
beautiful metro stations on the planet
and there's a tractor going by and then
there's a BMW going by and then there's
an amazing restaurant and then there's a
place called mafia I don't know how the
food I think it's a chain I doubt it's
amazing food but what I'm saying is just
like all it's either that extreme or the
other extreme
[Music]
they seem to be enjoying themselves okay
there's a lot of pessimistic negative
got it but there's also a lot
of this young vibrant positive energy
here and it seems connected it seems
like you walking down the streets and
you're part of something bigger than
yourself way more diverse than anywhere
I've seen in Ukraine so far so you're
seeing you're seeing black people you're
seeing Arabs you're seeing Asians it
felt a little bit more like home in that
respect because it was all mixed up and
that's because of the universities
people come from all over to go to these
universities and then you got these
parks right in these parks going to keep
Park was the one I spent the most time
in old ladies dancing there's there's
kids on on carnival rides there's people
riding bikes there's quiet spaces
there's people shooting guns at balloons
like it's all all mixed oh and all these
like these ropes these rope apparatuses
for kids it's like a kid's paradise in
there
[Music]
and it's buff the grass perfect the the
whole space is like perfectly clean
there's all these cleaners out there and
they really take they really take pride
in their parks here there's no trash on
the ground it's nice and so I walked
around for a bit and then took this
gondola ride and there's a gondola in
the park and cool unique experience for
me but if I'm going to talk about a park
where people are connecting to take your
kids to do a whole host of different
things then the gorgeous Gorge Park is
the coolest number one place I've seen
for that
[Music]
look the Ukrainians know how to do the
whole park thing really well like
professional where the Americans are
crazy on the whole safety thing Ukraine
goes the opposite direction I'd say
really close but you could push it
you're flying into this thing and I like
the fact okay you don't want to lose
your kid flying out of a gondola but I
think like people get it they drop
they're not stupid about it but I like
the fact that you're responsible for
yourself there are no there no no signs
little kid like cooking himself in the
kids doing it and then he's gonna fly
across the zip line there's no way that
would exist at home
there's more safety precautions there'd
be like three people checking it
I don't know it's better or worse
seriously I don't but I sort of find it
entertaining to to observe this place
and like how how free it is then I met
this guy okay poor Daniel I captured him
on the streets recently out of the
University and looks like what like
Hogwarts from what room did I never read
Harry Potter
come on let me see the movie now I
haven't he's only sorry Daniel I think
you're only 22 right 23 but somewhere
around there I mean that building that
building is an architecture porn now you
know what I mean it's like it's
absolutely beautiful
yes but inside you're saying it's a
cockroach there's nothing going on in
there when I will move to United States
and first CEO cockroach I was so wait
you saw your first cockroach in the u.s.
yeah congratulations
got a job for a trucking company
actually an American company see a
roommate Simon has got to live with you
and your girlfriend yes poor guy
no I mean okay like it I mean he likes
amazing let's go no no just you're
taking it out from context no I mean
dude you said we have to have a pass
inside to get in the university yes but
if we don't have it so but I'm in with
the babushka mafioso in Kiev and they're
all connected like like Facebook in a
stream so yeah
babish come on PSN knows more about you
yeah then you know yourself she knows
what you're gonna if you're gonna be
successful
it's gonna work out with your girlfriend
we get married all these things you
don't even know right now check it out
you know what this is here in the Metro
like this in this what you're standing
up
Stalin built them this way as a bomb
shelter like so seriously if the neuter
if the nukes came that the population of
the city would come down in here in
Ukraine
no no no we didn't care no no that this
was out why was mil seriously that's
what I was told at least cool told you
how do I said like there's a lot of
mature young people I would say I have
been in Spain over there and Poland but
it doesn't count it because quality is
almost Ukraine again and I will move to
George yen in November so if I turn one
year like it's gonna be my such country
so I mean so that's amazing
[Music]
Marty many years oh yeah where you would
really taste on your recommendation with
my friends in USA very good look at that
and that's cool it's huge
that's what she said do you know that
joke yes I know everyone's from Wayne's
World a movie in the 80s before you were
born
okay yes hold so if you remember I saw
that could be your dad you already went
over this yeah well you didn't believe
me but it's true and there's an amazing
amount of wisdom I would say maybe I was
just totally lucky but I don't think
that's the case like I actually do think
that since sort of like the the the DNA
of this place Ukraine in general but I'm
gonna say my impressions here and Harkov
are like wow a lot of impressive young
people because I mean you can spend all
your life just working on the job just
making some monument when you were gonna
be like I don't know like Stevie was
just sitting in the chair thinking what
for I did spend the whole life just for
some money and and what is then nothing
and then there's Victoria she's 17 she
went to the US when she was 15 as an
exchange student and she ends up in the
deep south of the US and she talks like
she's finished all our mannerisms like
everything she does she talks like she's
from the deep south
[Music]
pick up this girl
ever think family in another part of the
world news
I met this guy here his name is Bogdan
Bogdan has an English English language
bomb and so he brings in all these
people from around the world it's a
super multicultural he created a cool
world here
what makes the places people always does
right and maybe I'm lucky maybe I got
lucky here I just seem to run into so
many cool people
and for those from here from this
beautiful city thank you
a lot of people reached out it's showing
everybody yeah I mean you can understand
what's up Peter
want to get a cool spyglass
this bridge situation here and how to do
this quite some attack
[Music]
you